on first of all congratulations to all
the three that's a pretty decent result
of Victory against the legend himself
Gary Kasparov did that fuel at the
beginning of the tournament for you no
actually because I wasn't really playing
well in that game I I have I had an
amazing position of the opening and then
I think I started just thinking every
move is good so and then Gary played
very well he defended he maybe even got
some chances to have an advantage and I
think he plundered at that moment for uh
nepo he was saying that he's really
enjoying those uh 10 minutes before the
round analyzing with his peers do you
feel the same way and how do you feel
about your team let's see all right I
mean it's amazing this is like a dream
come true for NHS player I mean I
understand that this is a you know chess
players chess I would say I understand
maybe for public it's difficult to
follow Fisher random but the amount of
joy we get playing this I don't know if
anything can be compared because well
the reason for it we make mistakes on
first couple of moves it shows that the
game is actually
eternal
I mean there is no solving to this game
and it also shows that you know we have
a lot to learn about Chess because you
know when you blunder and move two or
you make a mistake on move one it means
uh you know this is a really an amazing
game you know because after all I mean I
personally spent 30 years studying chess
and still you know in this game I make
mistakes early on so it's it's a
wonderful feeling and also for us as
commentators I'm sure also for the fans
out there seeing ideas that similar to
what nepo was showing with like long
castle and then Knight E3 Checkmate that
move 20 is just incredible Now take us
through this last game against Dominguez
yeah so we analyzed this with Fabi
because Fab is my partner internalize
and well he's a good friend of mine so
we thought E4 e592 makes the most sense
and here we thought F5 has to be played
uh with the idea why was that
yeah we thought uh if black you know uh
allows white you know if he goes Knight
F6 for example instead of F5 then a
white has F4 we thought this this can be
very unpleasant and you know everything
is connected with the not nice position
on E8 yep because you really want to
bring out that knight from E8 and
which side gets you know to block that
Knight with the pawn on E5 gets the
advantage with the pawn only five or the
pawn on yeah or E4 so that's why you
wanted to play F5 as black in this
position yeah we thought this is kind of
interesting is this a move at this point
uh yeah as far as it's quite a possible
move we thought maybe this will be 97
you know maybe maybe two
water down very soon so we're thinking
something like F5 EF
and the
yeah we thought this this might be
slightly better I saw you very often not
necessarily liking taking the queen out
with queen of five but rather choosing
yeah but 96 D4 is the issue I think
if you take on F5 uh take only five and
if you take here Bishop takes H6 no 94 I
thought simply take take you know and
then just play
yeah hit 4G for anything I think it
looks good the rule comes into the game
quickly the reason because you have more
developed feces is that correct uh I
think it's just no the real reason why
white is better here is that both bishop
and Knight are a d8 and E8 have the
ideal position on F6 okay and both of
them cannot
occupy that position right so one of the
pieces is going to be stuck because if
black tries to put the bishop on F6
phone on D5 and Knight on D6 you always
have this bishop F4 and the Knight is
kind of loose so that's the reason why
this is unpleasant for black makes sense
and he played move Knight to E7 yes uh
by the way he was also spending a lot of
time at this point yeah I think they
didn't really analyze 92. they didn't
look at 92. because if we don't play
Knight E2 I think uh black black has a
comfortable position yeah 97 he played
D4 this is six yeah the the thing I
thought he was going to do is to play
after Knight F3 Knight C6
yes I thought this was interesting
because I was thinking about D5 97 92 F5
F3
some kind of King's Indian I get to play
C4 and maybe it's a good same-ish for
white because I managed to kind of keep
the center intact
but after all he has the C6 A5 he should
be six it's also a queen takes F1 also
like that yeah just get some sort of an
end game like this yeah slightly better
for white but not a big deal
yeah and uh F5 somehow I thought is not
a good move but maybe I was wrong so E
Yeah taking on E5 of course possible but
AF looks logical
and now E4 I thought Knight G5 should be
a pleasant position for white because
you know b596
we get this
anything after I will play F3 you know I
got rid of my E1 Knight the Bishops are
starting to have a nice life definitely
looks good okay
so he took On d42 and Here Yeah Queen B5
is extremely unpleasant I felt
for him well there's a checkmating
threat in the position you have to worry
about Knight C6 first uh he decided to
take the passive route with Knight to E7
but probably the only way Rook to E1
C6 oh actually and now I see what I
blundered he had C5 here oh it's
embarrassing and if you take on E7
no you know what I blundered I forgot
that I cannot play Knight E6 it takes an
ic7
oh yeah this is so I had to play Queen
B3 first
oh yeah that's an embarrassing bunder of
course
so Queen to B3 in this position yeah in
order to have this now c596 and at least
you grab the Bishops have a better
position he did not see it either and
then it was a smooth sailing from here
yeah because
you didn't feel like he had any way out
anyway back into the game yeah yeah this
I think this rookie 4 is very precise
and it just finishes the game Levon
first of all congratulations on the two
victories what would you say is the
biggest factor of assessment in chess
960. whenever you see a new position
what are you looking for
Well normally you know uh if Bishops are
fancyed it gets much more boring because
you know you have to open the bishop but
in positions like this I think it's
quite exciting you you always look into
a possibility to get the center
and then you have to assess where your
positions are going to end up I mean
your pieces white pieces
and then of course where the king is
going to be so there's three factors are
extremely important because
quite often do you understand that G4
might be the best move in the position
in the start but then you're kind of you
know let's see what if what if I never
get to Castle
all those risks so the reason why this
game is such a an amazing game another
reason yet another reason is that you
have Chances with black all the time
and unlike regular chests were with
black you're really suffering here you
you have a chance to take take over
because well as you see we make early
mistakes all of us definitely uh you're
enjoying these rounds this game it's a
pleasure to see you play and we'll see
you in the next couple of days thank you
thank you one quick question for you uh
Lavon I like to draw your attention to
this move 18 because I think this is a
magnificently unique moment to fish a
random chess you made that you normally
if you're going to Castle queenside the
King on E1 has to go through the D1
square but you're permitted to Castle
bringing the Rook attacking the queen
because you didn't go through the check
did you go to the Arbiter and ask him
hey hey
am I permitted to Castle you knew that
you could castle and it's a winning move
it wins on the spot yes you know for
example yes sir another example I will
tell you maybe it's a secret for you but
for example when your king is only one
yes Rook is on H1 and Black's Queen
let's say is on D5
you can Castle short but you cannot
Castle long yeah it's correct the H5 H1
square is not a problem but this is a
this is unique in the sense you're
castling and attacking the queen on the
same turn you don't have that in regular
chess you Castle short the there's a
queen on the f file the king can't go
through F1 but a very very nice Lavon uh
congratulations on your score we'll see
you tomorrow thank you very much
absolutely we'll learn another day every
day